Okay,
let's get started.
So last time we looked at uh,
methane and ammonia and saw something
interesting about molecular orbitals,
we could give them the same name
as atomic orbitals. That is, if we,
and especially if we look at a low
electron density contour of the molecular
orbitals,
we see that what it looks like is an Adam
where the nucleus is split into pieces
right now that splitting into pieces
dis changes the potential energy for the
electron.
So you expect that to distort the orbital.
The electrons will move in the directions
that pieces of the nucleus of gone.
But then in addition to potential
energy control in the shape of orbitals,
kinetic energy also does, and that's
the same thing as it is in an Adam.
You have a thing with no nodes thing with
one node a and when you have one node,
you can have either a spherical node
or a planer node, and the plane,
there can be three planar nodes. So two
s and three two p's. You have the same,
the same,
exactly the same considerations apply in
a molecular orbitals and atomic orbital.
You have the kinetic energy, which comes
with curvature, which comes with nodes.
Now as you split the, the nucleus up
and pull pieces in different directions,
it doesn't have the same symmetry it had
when it was all together in the nucleus
as spherical kind of symmetry.
So the nodes get distorted,
but still you can see them there.
And we saw them last time and went through
all the occupied and vacant valence
orbitals of ammonia and methane and saw
how they looked like atomic orbitals.
This not surprisingly,
because it's so fundamental,
the potential energy to kinetic
energy applies to every system.
It applies to you, viewed
as a single atom, right?
With a Zillion electrons.
Okay. But anyway,
but pieces of moved around. So
the, so the orbitals change,
we'll look at a more at
two more complicated cases
and then we'll get onto a
different way of looking at bonding.
So we'll look at ethane and
methanol and we use, uh,
W I didn't tell you last time explicitly
where I got the molecular orbitals from.
I got them from my laptop.
There's a program,
that particular one is called
Spartan that I use. And it,
it calculates what molecular orbitals
look like using approximate molecular
orbital. That is, uh, uh,
Schrodinger equation kind of theory.
Okay? So let's just look at the
ones of ethane and methanol. Now,
both of these have seven
pairs of valence electrons.
There are also a core electrons.
And if we were looking at the
orbitals for all the electrons,
we didn't include those and
exactly how we're going to, uh,
count those.
You could do it one way or the other,
whether you consider the core electrons,
the one that's electrons,
just be part of the nucleus and then
treat the rest as the electrons you're
interested in, or whether you, uh,
whether you want to count the core
electrons to, you can do it either way.
But what you analogize,
the what depends on whether you count
them as part of the Nuclei airport.
It's only how we're going to compare
these molecular orbitals to the atomic
orbitals of are gone,
which has also seven electron pairs.
Okay? So, so there's, uh,
the two s orbital. I'm going
to start with that because,
because I'm going to pretend that that
red part is the core, that there's,
there's a one s which is core electrons.
But in this case,
here's my pedantic note on this subject,
which I just added. So if you have to,
before we had just one heavy Adam
carbon and methane nitrogen in ammonia,
right? So there was one, one s orbital.
Right now we have two heavy atoms,
carbon and carbon, and methane,
carbon and oxygen,
and methanol.
So they're too heavy atoms and
therefore to a boring core orbitals.
So for purposes of making analogies,
we'll use the atomic one s orbital,
uh,
of the Adam that were
analogizing things to,
to stand for all the molecular
core orbitals. You can do
it any way you want to.
We're not really interested in that.
We're interested in the valence Arbuckle.
So whether I start with the one s or the
two s depends on how I'm handling the
core electrons is not a big deal.
Anyhow,
let's pretend it's the two s of Argon
here and we're going to compare it with
this lowest valence level
molecular orbital of, uh,
of ethane.
Now we can wrote,
as I do this on the left side of the,
of the pictures,
I'm going to show one view
and then because it's more
complicated than a methane
and methane and ammonia,
where I'm going to also show a
picture rotated by 90 degrees.
So I'm going to rotate around that axis.
And on the right I'll show a different
view of the same orbital. Okay?
So that's the lowest valence
level molecular orbital of ethane.
And it's not very exciting.
It's just a distorted sphere.
And you can see the way in which is
the store to this distorted vertically
because the two carbons are pulled apart.
So it's got sort of a narrow waist to it.
And then it's pulled out
where each of the protons, uh,
left the Middle Adam to, to come
out and, and be hydrogens. Okay.
Now if we look at, at a methanol,
it'll be a little different.
Can you anticipate how it might be
different if on the bottom we'll have ch
three again, but on the top instead of
having ch three we're going to have o h.
How do you think it might be
different in the way it looks?
It might be skewed more
towards the, Ooh, Jesus.
Okay,
so oxygen has a bigger nuclear charge,
so that's going to pull the lowest
energy orbital toward the oxygen.
That'll be one thing. We expect it
to be big, bigger, a top heavy. Okay.
What else about how the top,
we'll look.
How will it be different from
if it were a ch three yeah,
I can't hear very well.
Oxygen has lone pairs.
Now how is that going to change thing or
another way of saying the same thing as
has only one hydrogen up there. How's
that going to change it do you think?
Can speak, you have to speak up.
It's not going to be a symmetrical.
Which way is it going to be distorted?
To be unsymmetrical,
you have to speak up
toward the electron pair to just say,
I couldn't hear away from hydrogen.
Well,
how about the Proton goes out?
Does it bring electrons with it or
does it repel electrons? The Proton
speak up. It pulls. So it should
distort toward the hydrogen.
So here's what it looks like,
right? The top, it's top heavy,
as Angela said, and it's
distorted out toward the hydrogen.
There are no protons
pulling it to the top left.
And you see the same thing end on
there at the, uh, on the right. Uh,
okay. This is the next door
battle. What does that look like?
Obviously you can peak
in the middle and see,
it's obviously a two PZ orbital
with the node across the middle.
Okay. In both cases, now the,
the, the ethane cases symmetrical,
the other cases unsymmetrical.
Why is it unsymmetrical?
Because the first orbital pull
the electrons to the top, right?
So the next in the next door battle,
electrons aren't going to want to be at
the top so much because they're going to
be repelled by the other electron.
So there'll be more toward the bottom
because the first ones went to the top.
Okay. Uh, okay. Then here's, here's a,
here's the next door. But you can see
there their energies marching up here.
The lowest one was asked then to PCT
and how to p x a law if we define the
horizontal axis here on the
left is the x axis. So again,
it's what you expect and it's pulled out
stretched vertically from being a dumb
bell by where the nuclei went.
Uh,
and here's a two p y which we can see
more clearly on the right perpendicular to
the two px. Okay. And, um,
notice obvious that it's
obviously so that the,
the methanol orbital will be less
symmetric in all cases than the one for,
for ethane.
But still we can recognize the
nodes because they must go that way.
It must be a no nodes,
one node of three different
kinds and so on. Okay.
Now this is three s you notice it has
the node that we don't see the one that's
down near the nuclei, right? In fact,
two nodes down near the nuclei,
one for each of the heavy atoms,
but then this now has another,
uh,
spherical or approximately
spherical nodes.
So we have that extra red lump
in the middle. On the top.
We're blue in the middle.
Just just to review.
What's the difference between red and
blue on the top of the computer decided to
draw it with red in the middle on the
bottom and decided to draw it with blue in
the middle. What do, what do
those colors mean? Yeah, Kathy.
They mean positive and negative.
So which one is right?
Should it be positive in the
middle or negative in the middle.
Positive as a guest.
Wilson would you say why not?
Not really positive or negative. It's
just a different phase. Yeah, it's,
it's the sign of the wave function,
but you can multiply the wave function
by minus one any constant and it's just
as good as bad as before.
So it's arbitrary and the computer
was arbitrary and choosing the colors.
Okay. I think there's actually a function
that I could've changed that if I had
thought to do so.
So they'd be the same.
But actually it tells a story if I
leave them different. Okay. So here's,
here's the next one. Now this
is, if you look on the left,
now it's more clear where the
nodes are that that's a d, F,
z orbital.
The name x z means that the product of
x and z appears in the wave function,
right?
So when both x and z are positive,
then the product is positive
on the top right? Red,
right when the,
when x is negative and Z as positive,
the top left, it's negative,
the product. So that's why,
that's why it has the name x,
Z. Okay? And there's D, Y, Z,
which you see on the
right turn 90 degrees.
And here's the Dz squared,
which is that thing that has a donut
that goes around the middle, right? What?
It's hard to see the donut. Can
you see it? It's blue on top.
You can easily see the
red on the top left,
which is the what's blue in the middle,
right? The sign has changed, right?
But the doughnut is highly distorted
because as you go around first,
Proton on the top pulls it up than a
proton in the bottom, pulls it down,
then up down.
So it's like a crown.
That donut has been made
into a crown around the end,
right by the protons pulling it that way.
Okay.
Then here's a the the three peasy.
So it has the horizontal nodal plane,
but also it has a spherical node,
which you can see in either picture.
Really. Okay. Then here's
the three p why orbital,
which again has that spherical node,
but now the Planar node or approximately
planar node is vertical instead of
horizontal. So that, so let's
say on the top right there,
you have red on the right
and blue on the left,
there's a vertical node over which
changes sign going right to left.
Or here's the three p x,
or here's the three d x,
y,
which you don't see so well here, a o l
a but if you turned it down you would,
and here's the three d x squared
minus y squared, which again,
to see it,
well you have,
you'd have to turn it and
here's the four f orbital.
So you can see,
especially say on the in the top ones
compared with the atomic orbital that it's
exactly the same general pattern of nodes,
slightly distorted.
And incidentally, the, the uh, member,
all the n equals whatever n equals three.
All the orbitals had
the same energy before.
Now they don't have all the same energy.
Notice that they all have
different energies. None of
them are degenerate. Why?
Because that if you
broke the nucleus apart,
how stable a thing that
has that general shape,
like a dumbbell or a
cloverleaf or something,
how stable the electrons are in those,
in those lumps depends on whether
a proton got pulled into the lump.
If there happens to be a proton
in the lump where kinetic energy,
the node pattern wants it to be,
then that'll be unusually stable.
If the protons had been pulled someplace
where there is a node because of
kinetic energy,
then it won't be stabilized.
So that breaks the degeneracy
of these different,
different patterns that have
the same number of nodes.
That depends on where the,
how the potential energy changed. Okay.
Now, just finally and very quickly,
I want to look at one flouro ethanol,
which is a molecule that would have,
I think, no stability at all, but
you can put it into the, I mean,
as a practical matter,
you're never going to put it in a bottle,
but you can easily put it into the
computer and calculate what its molecular
orbitals would look like. And I did
it to show you something that's very,
very unsymmetrical and has Adam's
a very different nuclear charge.
Okay, so what will the very, very,
very lowest orbital look like,
do you think? For this thing,
it has, uh, a fluorine and oxygen,
two carbons and five hydrogens.
So what do you,
if you were an electron and you had
that set of nuclei arranged this way,
where would you want to go,
Elizabeth? Very nice. The left,
especially around the three. Now, what
would the very, very, very lowest,
and it should be more toward the left and,
and really close to the flooring.
It would be a one s orbital and mostly
on fluorine because that's where most of
the protons are, the most concentrated
Proton. So let's look, there's,
there's a smaller scale ball model so
that we can see really small orbitals and
there that's,
you're absolutely right.
It's the one s or it's
essentially the one s orbital.
A fluorine is the very lowest orbital.
What would be next if you were
suppose this was, you came up in,
this seat was already taken. Now where
would you go? The next electron, Zack.
Oxygen to the oxygen cause that's the
next highest concentration of protons.
And next,
where are we going next?
Steve, what do you say that the
one s of fluorine has taken?
The one s of oxygen is taken.
Where are we want to go next?
Pardon me. Oh, which carbon?
Why
and what does the proximity
have to do with it?
That the proximity means that the,
the, that the electrons that are on,
that Adam will have been drawn toward,
and we'll talk about this more later.
We'll have been drawn toward
the fluorine and the oxygen,
therefore that Adam will have fewer
electrons are lower electron density.
Right? Therefore, it's a better place
for other electrons to go. Okay.
So you'd expect the next one to be the
middle of carbon. Right. And finally,
of course,
it's going to be the second carbon,
the one that's remote from the
electronegative high nuclear charge Adams.
Okay. Now, now we've done all the one
ss, so we can look at what's interesting,
the valence or, but also the ones that
are going to be involved in bonding.
These don't have anything
to do with bonding. Okay. So
there's the first one. Does,
uh, uh, uh, Russell told me
something about the shape of
this. Does it surprise you?
Yeah,
it has no nodes except it actually has
little nodes down near the nucleus cause
it's actually more like a two s
orbital in that respect. Okay.
Because of the core electrons.
So it has tiny nodes that we
don't see around the nuclei,
but it has no nodes within the valence
big orbitals that we're looking at.
So it's like an s orbital.
Right. And it's big where the,
where the nuclear charge as big as
you say. Okay. What's the next one?
Gonna look like?
Any ideas?
Pardon me? Toward the oxygen.
Will it also have no nodes?
No. The next highest
orbital has to have a node.
Where do you think the node will be? What
orbital would that look like? Sort of,
it'll be highly distorted. But what
if this is the s orbital? Right?
What's gonna be next?
Oh,
Elizabeth.
It's as if it switched. But
with the Planar node. Let's see.
Right, right. So the first one
was, you were right, Russell,
that this one should be big on oxygen, but
notice that, hey, it's like a p orbital.
It has that horizontal node
because it's higher kinetic energy.
Okay. And then this one
that's on the carbons, right?
Mostly, but it's a p why it
has a vertical node. Right?
So it's negative, say on the fluorine
and oxygen and positive on the carbons.
Or if we rotate this one
around a horizontal access
to look at it from the side,
it looks like that. And you can see
that it's a p y kind of orbital.
Well, Elizabeth,
technically pure business,
right? We are. We're just
saying there are, now
there are analogous to p orbitals
because it has to be the same.
The orbitals must go in order
of the number of nodes, right?
So the same thing as in
an Adam or into molecule.
You go from no nodes to one node and
there are three ways of getting one node
spherical or distorted sphere planes
or distorted planes if the nuclei are
pulled around, so on. So they're, they're
really very much likely atomic orbitals.
Okay.
Or this one.
Now that's an interesting one
because that's like a hybrid orbital.
It looks like the orbital up here.
It's a mixture of s with p.
Everybody see how that is.
It's a big sort of blue lobe on the
top and a small red wood on the bottom.
And also the next one is the other one,
the hybrid that points
the other direction.
Another combination of the
s and p that points down.
Okay. And then this one, it
looks like d x, y again, right?
It's sort of a cloverleaf with two nodes.
Okay.
So that's all I want to do with that
and we won't go any further with it.
This is just an interesting
way of looking at how,
how molecular molecular orbitals are
really just like atomic orbitals and have
energies for the same reason,
except the potential energy gets screwed
up by breaking the nucleus and pulling
pieces around, but in an
understandable way. And the,
the nodes get distorted
because of this. Okay. Now, uh,
now we're getting into really the w w
we just looked at this view of at the
single United atom view,
but the other view is the one that's
going to be more generalizable.
And that's the one where we
looked at bonding, right?
So you have to probe a little harder to
get a qualitative understanding of what
chemical bonds are.
And that's where we're going to do now
by choosing a higher contour it with
which to look at a molecule.
Now, true molecular orbitals,
to the extent that orbitals
are true altogether, why
aren't they true altogether?
Why aren't orbitals true altogether?
Yeah.
Does he have many electrons? You can't
have independent electrons, right?
You can't have orbitals but
we're approximating thing
by orbitals trying to take
or electron interaction into account
in a sort of a lefthanded way by
self-consistent field
or something like that.
Because it's much easier if we can
divide the whole into a bunch of parts,
each of which we can understand.
So to the extent that
molecular orbitals are true,
the kinds of things I've just been
showing you calculated with laptop, uh,
they extend over the whole
molecule. They're not local, right?
Except like the one s of
fluorine was local, right?
But mostly they're there
go over the whole molecule.
But bonds are thought of and has have
always been thought of as interaction
between pairs of Adams.
So we want to divide things
completely differently.
And look at the bonds now at Pairwise Llc,
a Oh molecular orbitals.
Now what's an Lca?
Oh,
it's a sum or a linear combination,
right?
A weighted sum of atomic orbitals.
So here's an example,
PSI, which is an orbital. What's that?
A function of position of what?
One Electron.
So it's a function of x one y one Z one
we're talking just about electron one.
So the wave function for electron one we
say is one over the square root of two
times one atomic orbital plus
another atomic orbital right?
Now, have you ever seen adding
orbitals like that before?
That's what hybridization is.
We added an s and P,
but this is different because
when we added SNP before,
they were on the same nucleus and we
did it to get a new orbital for that
particular nucleus for that Adam,
right to distort it one way or the other,
for example, or to rotate
a p orbital. Right?
But this is very different because we're
adding orbitals that are on different
nuclei. A nucleus, a a nucleus. Be.
See the difference
adding is just the way functions are
numbers. We just add the numbers.
But in the first case,
hybridization,
those two functions were on the same
nucleus. Now they're on different nuclei.
What? We're heading together. Okay.
Now why is it sensible to think that you
might get pairwise molecular orbitals
that can be expressed like this?
How do you interpret an orbital Corey?
What good is an orbital?
What do you use it for?
Yeah,
but what?
So what do you use it for?
Great.
And how do you get probability
from the wave function?
You have the wave function. How do you get
the probability density? You Square it.
So do you see why we have a one
over the square root of two in this
plus when we square it,
that's going to be a half and we're
going to get a half of atomic orbital,
a squared and of atomic orbital B squared.
So it's a half of each of them.
That's why they have the one over
the square root of two. So let's,
let's go on with this.
Suppose we have a hydrogen molecule
and suppose that the nuclei at a great
distance from one another so far,
they don't interact or
negligible interaction.
They're very far apart.
What would you expect the
one elect the lowest energy,
one electron wave function to look like?
The one possibility is that the electron
could sit exactly halfway between the
two nuclei. Right. Is
that a reasonable place?
Is that the low energy place for
it to be? Lucas, what'd he say?
The attic probability density
there is not the greatest thing.
Why not? Why shouldn't
the electron sit? Right?
It's the two nuclei are this far apart.
And I don't mean to angst terms apart.
I mean two meters apart.
There's a proton here in a proton here.
Is the electron most likely to
be here and halfway between? No.
Where would it be most likely
rolling year to one of the two atoms.
And which of the two,
suppose you took the long view,
suppose you averaged it over,
uh,
18 zillion millennia time average.
Sometimes it would be near this one.
Sometimes it would be near this one. Okay.
What would it be if you
took a really long view?
Both and half here and half here.
So the wave function,
when you square it,
you want it to be half looking like
this Adam and half looking like this,
Adam. Then you see the
time average, right?
It might take a long time to achieve
that average because it take a long time
for the electron to tunnel two
meters. Right? But in the very,
very long time it would look like that.
So we know what we want it to look like.
What we want is that
the probability density,
the square of this one electron wave
function should look half of the time,
like the atomic orbital,
a squared and half of the time like atomic
orbital B squared. So on time average,
it's half of one and half of the other.
Everybody with me?
So that's what the s yeah,
Nate.
Well, because I'm telling
you what it looks like.
It's got to look half like
this and half like this, right?
So the square of it has to be this.
So all we have to do to find
the wave function is what
if we know what square is?
All we got to do is take the square root
and we've got the wave function. Bingo.
There's the square root,
right? So that is a reasonable
way to write the wave function.
One over the square root of
two times atomic orbital,
Aa plus atomic orbital be clarity.
You have a question?
Just like a bracket is two things.
Inside the sprouts you have four things
that come out of distributing 100 you
can't just put the squares.
Okay, now Clara, you're
going to help me out.
How big is that? That's a number.
It's the product of a top. What?
Atomic orbital a assigns numbers
everywhere in space. Everywhere in space.
Atomic orbital be assigns
numbers everywhere in space.
So at some point in space,
atomic orbital be assigns a number and
atomic orbital a assigns a number and a
times B is the product of those two
numbers. How big is that product?
How big is atomic orbital?
A here?
This a meter away from the
Proton. Great. And how,
how big is the atomic orbital be there?
Great.
Now how big is atomic
orbital a here? Great. Okay,
so now how big an error do we
make if we neglect a times B,
where do we make an error?
Do we make an error here?
Do we make an error here? Do
we make an error here? Yes. No,
we make an error. Yeah, sure enough,
we make an error. How big is the error?
Uh, it's, it's negligible.
Does, it's a great distance.
Okay,
so at great distance we can forget that.
So now it's easier to take
the square root, right?
Okay.
The Old Fox up here,
Huh?
Okay.
Now your problem is what happens if
h two is that the bonding distance,
what if they're only an onstream apart?
Now there should be a problem, right?
Because because a times B is not going
to be negligible everywhere. Now,
okay, so now that's going to come
back. So now we got an error, right?
Or do we?
Let's think what that does.
Okay,
so if we approximate the molecular orbital
as a sum of atomic orbitals this way,
then it looks very good near
the nuclei because near a,
it looks like a near B,
it looks like B.
And if we want a square it to find
the electron density we do at this at.
But if we then subtract what the
Adams would give for electron density,
now what does this remind you of where
we look at the total electron density and
subtract the Adams? This.
So we're actually looking
for the difference density.
Everybody with me on this.
So we're going to subtract the Adams,
which is one half a squared
and a half B squared, right?
If we subtract, what do we get? What
we get for a difference density,
we get a times B.
So we get the difference.
Electron density,
which is due to overlap.
And what do I mean by overlap?
I mean that is only important in regions
where both of them have a finite value,
right? The product of a and B is
negligible. If a is zero, it's negligible.
If B is very, very small, right?
So it's only where they overlapped,
the two functions have simultaneous
values that you care, okay?
Now that thing,
the thing that's that the bonding,
the difference,
density is really a byproduct.
That's a little bit of a pun
because it's a product, right?
But it's a byproduct of squaring the
sum of what player didn't like about it.
So the very thing you didn't like is
what's going to give rise to bonding
density in that.
Neat.
Okay? But notice that here
we're multiplying a times B,
but this is completely different instance
of multiplying from what we had before.
Right?
Before we multiplied two orbitals to
try to get a two electron wave function.
This has nothing to do with this because
both of these are functions of the same
electron.
It's like one electron that we're
squaring here that so this a times B,
this product is overlap
comes from the squaring.
It was when we squared it
that we got that. Okay.
Now, because we have this extra
term, we have not only one,
half a squared plus B squared,
which would sell,
what would the probability of that,
what's the probability of a squared summed
over all space or integrated if it's
normalized and this one and what's this
whole quantity one because of the half,
but actually we've got bigger than that,
right?
Because we added the overlap term to it,
So it's actually not going to be a half.
It'll have to be something
a little less than a half.
So that will sum up to one if
we want to normalize it. Okay,
so they're going to be those
less than a half's there. Okay.
Now what does that do? That
shifts electron density, right?
We're taking electron density away from
where the nuclei are from a square and
be square,
and where is the electron density going?
Because we're using less than
a half to begin with, right?
We're taking electron density away.
There's going to be,
we're subtracting more than was
there at the beginning, right?
Which means that we're going
to have negative electron
density in the difference
map. Electrons are going away from
the Adams. Where are they going to?
Into the region where there's overlap,
right?
So they go away from there
into the overlap region.
So this is just like what we
were seeing with X-ray. Okay?
So that overlap the a times B
term is what creates bonding.
And we've seen this before.
Remember when you have wells far apart,
the the wave function is a sum of the
two. We saw this in one dimension, right?
But if they come close together, you get
a wave function that looks like that,
which we looked before just from the
point of view of the energy and saw that
that would stabilize the particle
because it's got less curvature,
less kinetic energy,
right?
But also the electron density
grows in the middle, right?
So from the point of view of the
electron distribution, that was whole.
That was the glue holding
the atoms together.
So it's held together both because the
energy goes down and because you put this
glue in the middle, which is what
causes the energy to go down. Okay?
So that's bonding.
And remember we also had this,
so as the energy went up in the middle,
when the energy is lower here
than it was in the atoms apart.
So you the the,
so the nuclei push one another apart.
Now without the glue in the middle.
And that was anti-bonding.
So we've seen it before in one dimension,
but it's true in three dimensions as well.
Now let's think about this again.
So here's, here's a, here's Adam a. Now,
where is the square of
that function significant?
Is that significant there? No. Is it,
is it significant there? Yeah, it's a
little bit significant. At least there's,
how about there?
A little bit, right? Okay.
Now suppose we have another
atomic orbital there.
Now where is the product
significant of a Times B.
Okay. So is the product a
times B significant there?
No. Uh, is it significant there?
Nick? What do you say? Why not
speak up small?
What's very small?
The value of a no, no. The value of a,
there is something we said that before
when we were looking only a day.
It's not very big, but
there's a significant value.
But how about the product,
Josh?
The value of B is very small there.
So the product is going to be very
small. How about, how about there?
Oh, now they're equal in there
halfway between their equal.
So both of them are a little bit small,
but their product is still significant.
Right?
Only in this region where they overlap.
Is that product significant?
Okay.
So at the center notice that
a, the Cya, the numbers,
Cya signs and the numbers.
Ib Siberia signs are the same number.
So two times CYA CIB is as large
as CIA squared plus diabetes,
right? Cause CIA time CIB
is the same as Cya squared.
So the electron density is nearly doubled
in the middle from what it would have
been if it had just been to Adams.
So that's the region of significant
overlap and that's what we care about.
So the overlap,
integral,
summing this product or
integrating it over all that space,
that's a certain density, right, that
we squared in order to get that right.
That's part of the density.
So we some that did the density that
comes from that product overall,
uh, space, and that's
called the overlap integral.
If the atoms are very far apart,
the overlap integral is essentially zero.
If the Adams are close together,
the overlap orbital will be finite.
And the better the, the, the
more the orbitals overlap,
the bigger the overlap integral obviously.
So that and that majors,
the net change that arises on bonding the
difference density as we've just seen.
Now,
let's look at some,
some practical exam or not with
some theoretical examples here.
So let's look at, uh, at, uh, uh,
the total electron density as
calculated for two w adding two,
one s orbitals of hydrogen at the
appropriate distance for h two, right?
This was done 40 years ago and published
in the Israel journal a chemistry. Okay.
Now, and here's, so on the left,
we have the total electron density that
you'd calculate from that very simple
thing. One over the square root
of two a squared, a plus B,
one of the squares do a plus B, and
you square it, you get the density,
and that's the density contour debt
0.025 electrons per cubic, uh, uh,
uh, a zero the unit of distance. Okay.
Now on the right is
the difference density.
So from that thing on the left,
we've subtracted the atomic orbitals,
the atomic electron densities,
and you see exactly what you expect.
It builds up in the middle where there's
overlap and it at the expense of the
Adams. You know, Russell? Oh,
uh,
I think it's the h two molecule.
I'm sure. I'm sure it's the age too. I'm,
they aren't so fantastically different
because the two electrons are in the same
orbital.
Two electrons can be in the same orbital,
so one will be twice as big as the other.
Qualitatively,
they'll look very similar.
And I think this is the h two molecule,
but it might be the eye on, I'm
not sure. Okay. Uh, at any rate,
the contours on the right
are much smaller. Remember,
different density is much
smaller than total density.
So what you see is that it's contoured
at 0.04. So you have one, two,
three, four, five contours.
So you get up in the middle to 0.02
electrons per cubic [inaudible].
That's how much bonding has
changed things at the maximum.
Okay. Now the energy that's
calculated with this very, very,
very crude wave function,
just one half,
one of the square to two times the
sum of the two atomic orbitals,
the energy you calculate that
is 92.9% of the true energy.
That's pretty darn good,
right?
But almost all of that energy that you
calculate was already present in the
separate atoms, were not interested
in the energy of the separate atoms,
were interested in how much it
changes when you make a bond,
which is a small difference
between large numbers.
So it turns out that although we're
within 7% of the true total energy,
this simple model only calculates about
50% of the change in energy that came
from putting them together,
right? Which is much smaller.
Okay,
so high accuracy is required to calculate
a correct value of the bond energy.
The simple thing won't do it well.
It gets, it's in the right direction.
You're halfway there so it's
pretty good start, right? But uh,
to do the difference as in the same
way you needed high precision to do Xra
difference maps,
you need better orbitals than this.
If you want to calculate
good bond energies,
so you need to make the orbitals
better. Okay. Now that, so,
but already we can take heart that the
very crude just model shows most 52% of
the energy of the bond and it shows the
electron density building up by 0.02
electrons per cubic bor radius.
And what we saw qualitatively it was there
was a shift from the Adam to the bond
of electron density.
Okay.
Now we can adjust the molecular orbital
to get a better approximation of the
truth thing.
How will we know when we've adjusted it
and it's gotten better if we adjust it
and get a lower calculate,
a lower average energy?
I should have said the lower average
energy because if we don't have a true way
function, we get different
values for the total energy.
The kinetic won't exactly offset the
potential as you move from place to place,
but then if you get the
lowest average energy,
then that is by definition almost more
realistic because you can easily prove
that the true energy is
the lowest possible energy
that makes a certain amount
of sense. The lowest possible
calculated energy is the true energy.
So if you change your wave function
and get a lower average energy,
you're closer to the truth.
Okay?
That's called the variational
principal. Okay, so here,
here we've changed the form of the wave
molecular oracle and how did we change
it? What is a one? What does a
one s orbital look like? Kate,
do you remember the form
for a one s atomic orbital?
I can't hear it. It's
Angola. It's a sphere.
How does it change as you go out? Do
you remember? How does it depend on row?
The same way they all depend on row.
Anybody remember
either the minus row,
so it falls off exponentially.
At a certain rate and that rate,
how fast it falls off is determined
by the nuclear charge. Okay? Now,
one way to change that shape would
be change how fast it falls off,
right? It wouldn't be
correct for the Adam anymore.
We've already got the correct
solution for the atom,
but we could change the shape
of the thing by changing that x,
the how fast that exponent falls off.
And we could have very that in
the molecule using one half,
one of the square to, to
a squared plus B, right?
But those a plus B are no
longer true atomic functions.
There are a little fatter,
a little skinnier, okay?
And we can change how fat or skinny it
is until we get the lowest molecular
energy. See that? That's a way you
can vary it and find the best value.
And that's what was done here
to optimize the exponent.
And now you've got a total electron
density that looks essentially the same as
it did before. And if you look at the
difference density, how has it changed?
If you do this first,
notice that the energy got lower.
We're now to 73% of the
lowering of the bond energy.
So the total energy has gotten lower,
it's better.
And how is the electron density changed?
It got higher in the middle because what
we did was spread the exponent out a
little bit so you had more
overlap in the middle. Okay,
so this wouldn't have been good for
the single atom to spread it out,
but it gives a better function for the
molecule and it's still very, very simple.
And what you see it did is it increases
the bonding density and the bonding
strength. You get a larger shift
from the atoms to the bond. Now,
how else could you change the shape of
the atomic orbital in order to increase
the overlap some way other than making
a single exponential and having to get
fatter or thinner?
Can you think of some other way here?
Or you have an atomic orbital a sphere
and you want to change its shape so that
it overlaps better over
here, right? How could,
how could you change the shape of an
atomic orbital without doing really gross
damage to it?
Right.
Making it a cube or
something like that or align,
how could you change it?
So it looked pretty much still like an
Adam did as a lot of the virtues of the
atom. But it's shifted over here. Sam
can't hear. Yeah. How, how,
how am I going to write a function that
allows the electrons to shift in the
direction I want them
to. Lexi hybridize it.
We could hybridize the shift the
electron. So that's the next one. So uh,
so here we're going to,
instead of this,
we're going to hybridize it now
this particular calculation did the
hybridization and also did a little
self-consistent field calculation and the
hybridization left at 96.7% one s so
essentially it's still normal one s
orbital,
but they added 0.6% of two s which
expanded it a little bit cause two ss goes
further out than one s and
they added 2.7% have to pee.
Now why was there much but it was
two p much more helpful than two s
Lucas.
Yeah.
So it takes density from one side
and shifts it to the other. In fact,
this is precisely what
we saw before. Uh, um,
notice what it, what it did was, uh,
how much it includes increased the density
in the middle and notice now it's not
taking electron density
away from the nuclei,
which was a good place for electrons
to be. Where does it take it away from
out beyond the nuclei and
shift it to the middle.
So even before when it was an Adam
and a certain, here's the nucleus,
a certain distance out here and
a certain distance out here,
we're the same in energy for that,
Adam.
Now we've taken it from a place which
is which out here and put it here.
Right? Great idea. Well done Lexi.
So there's what it looks like.
You remember that's a 100%
one s it looks like that.
And if you change it to be hybridized
that way with Adam in a box,
it looks like this, right?
It's not much shift,
but it shifts from the left to the
right. Okay. And gives better overlap.
Okay. And, and, uh,
but it requires the Adam to be a little
bit less happy as an Adam because it's,
it's partly two s and two p. Now the
electrons are further from the nucleus,
but you make up for that by
having a better bond, okay?
Now notice that didn't change.
The energy very much went from 73% to 76%,
right?
We were already about the right energy,
but it changed the density a
lot to be what we want it to be.
Okay?
So there's a much bigger shift and it's
now from beyond the nucleus into the
bond, right? Uh,
and now we're going to do the
last thing we've done SCF already,
but now you have to do a higher level
calculation. That'll do correlation.
Take the correlation of
the electrons into account.
And if you add some correlation
calculation to this,
you now get 97,
90% of the bond.
If you did complete correlation,
you'd get 100% of the bond.
What does it mean to do a calculation
with complete correlation?
It means you don't have an error anymore.
You've raised,
used the really good calculation.
So already at this level that was
done 50 years ago, almost, uh,
you get 90% of the bond
and the bond density.
Notice what about the electron density?
It hasn't really changed all the,
all that happened was that the
electrons kept apart from one another,
but the average density was the same. So,
so already with just that hybridization,
we got very close to the truth in electron
distribution and three quarters of
the way to the truth in how strong a
bond is. So not a bad approximation.
So hybridization to give better
overlap is a great thing.
So the density wasn't changed,
but you've got a much better energy.
And how so? Because the electrons
kept apart from one another.
When you allow correlation.
Okay,
so here's a pairwise atomic orbital,
less than one half the square w one
of the square to two times a plus B.
And you can use hybridized orbitals.
And the virtues are,
it's very easy to formulate it to
understand. And it looks like Adam's,
especially when you get
down near the nuclei, uh,
and that you don't want that to change
because that's the main event for
electrons.
You get much more energy forming Adams
as we saw before than you do making,
making new bonds once you have
the Adams already. Uh, okay.
It builds up electron density
between the nuclei through overlap,
which is the source of bonding.
It's smooth,
smooth sy to lower the kinetic energy.
And then there's a pedantic footnote
here that actually there's a thing called
the varial Theorem,
which I'm not going to stress you with,
but that's that little bit
of there happens to be true,
but still we have the proper I
understanding of what's going on.
Uh, hybridizing aos provides flexibility
that gives you better overlap.
And if you use all the h like atomic
orbits, you have perfect flexibility.
You could make any shape
you want. Okay? But,
but we're going to keep it simple.
Use only s two s and two p orbitals to
hybridize because that'll give you most
of the way there.
And it's much simpler rather than to
try to mix five [inaudible] four bubbles
into it also. Okay. So that's
great. And when we square it,
we get this, which has the
overlap part that helps us out.
We have the Adams plus the bond, which
is the overlap, that product part.
Uh,
but we could have done the same thing
to get the same product as far as the
Adam's go. If we'd used a
minus sign instead of a plus
sign and combining things,
although then we would have changed
the sign of the overlap thing,
it would become minus. So we would
change it from being greater than,
less than to being greater than in order
to have it be normalized at the bottom.
Right. And that's the ante bonds. So we
get both the bond and the anti bond, uh,
by doing this. And now we're going
to go on next time to overlap,
which we've already introduced.
And also the concept of energy match.
And when you put these two together,
you'll really understand bonding.